[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello happy Tuesday
welcome to shinobi training with Eric
and John Luke yes who have we but yeah
you beat it I beat it I mean which is
good yeah
don't there's a decision you'll have to
make at some point don't be dumb like me
unless you want the achievement then do
it I'll probably make some saves or
something otherwise for ending so Jesus
uh it's not right good
you know what just find out oh it
actually says oh you're gonna do it I'm
just you're just gonna do it second
place here yeah choice huh do you have a
safe what yeah okay I'm just gonna okay
yeah okay all right it's fine yeah cuz
you're trying to get another end anyways
right okay here we go all right let's do
it record yeah I can get one I'm gonna
I'm just gonna show ya a shadow play
work sounds great yeah yeah might need
this for later you know yeah yeah okay
let's get started here oh dude you get a
chance to beat the I thought about that
I'm just like nervous now that's a lot
of pressure
yeah it's also looking plus I don't know
how much harder the enemies are they
change that's what we're finding out oh
yes we're gonna we're gonna learn
everything that's different about new
game+ oh I also meant to change it in
English I wanted to do the English skip
the intro right like yeah let's just
let's just get this done even though it
is like the one of the only cinematics
it's pretty cool I owe you lose all your
prosthetics oh damn you do yeah I still
love my own yeah okay alright so you
think it comes back to later oh you got
courage arm I got all this stuff what's
the Karoshi arm uh crows charm let's
find out let's learn what's going on I
keep my mask fragments I kept my I kept
all my okay you have all your texts I
kept my prayer beads I kept all my
remnant up so many spoilers no you're
getting into this is New Game+
charms even cruel place on the wolf
person in secret after he lost
like oh it's just his resurrection okay
whatever I thought it was something
special for some reason I thought okay
you just maybe that's something you
don't get the first time through I don't
know I got a sound and switch just wants
to English this crime I wanna I wanna
hear I've heard people on Twitter being
like hey you should give it a shot
it's parently pretty good I might not
actually able to do it in-game we're at
EC he's on Xbox one controller for those
asking yes it's a PC Xbox one controller
did I beat dark souls 3 ass box night
yes I did I did not be DLC though I
didn't kill Ross wave slaves with a
slave slave night when slave night
something slave night with the Jean
Gabriel Gail Gail Gail yeah I did not be
sleigh tonight Gail I was close though
and then I stopped trying for some
reason and then there's like a secret
boss after that like a dragon or
something we were playing PC as you saw
his shadow played can't shadow play on
xbox seat at least not yet
I'll show me how you don't get caught
here because both playthroughs I kind of
just like book it under that thing and
they saw me but like they don't actually
do anything oh you know why I kind of
like skirted and ran through there oh we
can each drop that guy yeah yeah done it
apparently now you're in the other
dialogue you turned it in English no I
didn't I couldn't I think I have to do
it from the main menu the outskirts
for those who know we're gonna be
skipping through dialogue here that's
not we already know you know itself
[Music]
I thought we were gonna see top bragging
Erick ps4 cam I played on PC too I wish
I played on ps4 cuz I would have
definitely hard saved so many times for
different things I probably could have
got every internet that framerate Oh is
it not so good
it's just PC you just lived that PC your
die PC elitist life smooth 60 watching
footage and I was like I dude no way no
way
after this have you found that I had
list stuff useful I'd like never use it
so basically yes okay so basically if
you guys didn't know there's headless in
the game you guys can look up the fights
if you want to when you beat them they
basically give you what you would get
from the sugars right from the different
candy you're using emblems instead of
eating the candy so you basically have
the candy at all times I actually went
through the entire playthrough without
using any of them I know somewhere
useful though yeah I didn't use a lot of
things to be honest like like we found
out that tip from body today about the
wellses balloon that's pretty good
that's a pretty good I'm gonna stealth
all in you can't stealth all of it wait
isn't this new dialogue yeah wait a
minute I don't remember this you skip
through all of it oh you just gave up
something that you didn't have the first
time but in your care insist you take it
oh shoot oh I didn't read I couldn't
read it it's a charm that he gave me
okay yeah Biden did you hear what he was
saying any of it dude screw it man let's
do it I'm gonna sing oh you love me I
think I know what this I might have I
might have you have chosen the path of
further hardships you know revive i
cannot resurrect anymore i chose a new
resurrect path we're going we're going
all-in baby oh yeah well you do that to
your suckas for the stream okay well if
you kuroh sharm as
turn that down a little bit kuroh charm
as we mentioned is is the revived
ability so you can turn that off in your
new game+ which is kind of insane it
kind of makes some sense I guess but but
I'm curious like you get anything out of
that bill other than just doing it for
your satisfaction of doing it well you
get you get your character itself said
that you enjoy suffering so I suppose
that's how you do it question to both of
you how many times did you died -
butterfly - old lady oh I died a lot the
first time a butterfly a fair amount she
was like a good hour for me something
like that I don't know I judge it by
time because like you know sometimes you
kind of throw away your your first wow I
didn't even know you could do that I
kill the first two guys first all right
you know yeah all these easy folks feels
good
I've been having to deal with some
harder guys and it's not fun here
although the one skill that I still suck
at that I think I implore people to get
better at is McKee recounting yep I
still don't do a good job I end up like
just like like dodging instead of
countering but it's such a good skill
that's like if you master right
[Music]
the life Bree the one who uploaded the
tips and secret videos on gamespot
gameplay at air
no well collaboration mostly John Luke
and Matt Espen le were the ones who
culminated a lot of that list I just
tried to help remember to guard to lose
your posture right one of our hot tips
it's okay like during high apex team I
didn't even follow one of our hot tips
either so Jack called me awkward but
yeah I was John Luke and Matt and then I
just helped here and there with either
some of the gameplay capture or you know
whatever tips I can vacuum it's kind of
a collaborative process no that's fine
it's the warm-up sesh you know when you
get back into it sometimes you're just
like oh what am i doing again how does
one parry I play it on a 1050 Ti and
it's super laggy for me it looks like my
laptop is messed up
ah 1050 T I should be okay but obviously
you're gonna have to turn down some
stuff I've been a super fortunate that
I've been playing on a twenty seventy on
a laptop which has looked really good so
that there's that one benefit that I
guess I'm getting from playing PC and
not ps4
I'm really curious how this is no
resurrection yeah what is the review
coming I believe I heard maybe today is
what I was what I've heard don't hold me
to that but that's that's it's a rough
estimate of what I heard
this game is hard yes it is hmm it
definitely is a learning experience even
if you come from a Souls born game or
like playing the souls boring game just
because it kind of breaks some of the
mold from that it still has elements
obviously but you know all right man
here we go
oh no revived though yeah yeah no no
revived sorry you have three pellets I
don't think you got a revived during
this part now you did oh man III assume
I can't back out on that like once I've
done this no maybe you can ask him again
maybe talk to him hey I want my charms
they actually can I have that I can
really damn do you want to give me that
maybe you'll get it after this maybe
sequence okay I mean this is all for the
stream I'll probably won't do an actual
at least I think it'd be fine for the
most part I mean like at this point for
me outside of like actual boss fights
the revive is more of like do I care
about losing money or more about the
dragon rot oh yeah that's true can I get
about to see if I know anyone but dragon
rot really only affects kind of
your ability to do side quests so that's
that's the one move I do always run away
Oh nope never mind immediately died well
yeah well you're probably used to the
gourd - I'm used to like the good ol
slow region of a pellet I wasn't
expecting dude his his slash took off
like 30 percent though yeah that was a
long that's definitely more than I
remember yeah in the original game it's
New Game+ so okay so I have my
prosthetic now so do I have them all
yeah okay good you keep everything did
you get down the path quite a bit I got
to like level five we're tier five is
what he called I'll be the last now that
would be one thing I would say too is
like if you notice that go there you go
so you can't turn it on and off what
happens if I a meddling woman what you
will
so do I haven't limited choices I'm
curious okay so you let him keep it then
right because this case because you
don't want to take it right or are you
saying that you take it and you can give
it back
yeah can I can I do this as many times
as I well I think so like hey we know
you did you regret that from the
tutorial so I didn't take it back God
why is your this decision cannot be
undone Oh or she want to take back the
charm and avoid the path of additional
her shame this is new game+ god of war
so he has all be like vitality and
posture he gained from the first
playthrough so his that's why his health
bar so big however if you notice when
he's fighting getting to row like all of
Ganesha rose damage was like way higher
than you would it would be the first
time you fought him so it looks like I
can still cancel out of it so you I
think it basically gives you one way I
regret this I'll get it back but I think
it only lets you do it once okay so are
you gonna probably try playing without
it let's do it if you need it's being a
thing but we'll come back but that seems
to be like they give you one free like
hey you regret this no worries
philanthropy or a kay Binn Jenko saying
I wonder if this is
so like a hard mode like the Harmonia
general because that dude hit you super
hard compared to the first playthrough
fight oh definitely yeah like New Game+
that's your shadow we haven't unlocked
it yet but yeah as you unlock more
skills that tree will open up oh yeah
that's the wine I just like oh you
didn't I think I missed one oh well that
sounds like a good way I have them all
okay maybe difficulty definitely goes up
in your game plus there's no doubt about
that that's no way it doesn't there's an
item behind the house oh there is yeah
but I think it's like a light coin purse
or something oh you know what I never
did you told me to go back to hanami
late game and I never did that so I
guess I should do that
yeah do you want know what it is some
people speculate that you can't actually
kill them no yeah yeah yeah which makes
sense yeah so I mean hey everyone here
in the chat you're here because we're
gonna be free to talk about maybe new
game+ stuff but yeah I mean like we
won't go into like maybe ending spoiler
stuff but will probably be loser talking
about you eventually get a ability to
kill him and then he's like oh you can
kill me and then you can kill him and
then you get an item for it yeah big
grand 2k have you been all the bosses I
have beaten all the bosses that I know
of except for one and one is tied to an
ending which John Luke is gonna try to
get so like there's multiple endings as
you could imagine with the from software
game and in some cases each ending I
think three out of the four as John we
can mention to my knowledge have
different bosses so I have technically
only not fought one that I know of which
is the one you are gonna try to get this
playthrough if that makes sense
yeah because the last boss of this
specific ending that you're gonna try to
do is different than the other endings
also have you ever gotten anything in
the box before in the often thing I've
never I don't know what ever gotten one
either
I've never found anything in that box
will there be added content ask Taylor I
have no idea like it wouldn't shock me
if they did DLC but I have heard me
that's a very fun software things yeah I
have heard nothing if they do do DLC I
would prefer them not to do two small
ones I'd rather have an old hunter sized
just like proper I'll give you the 40
bucks just gave me the proper DLC that
would be sick actually I would I don't
know I have a very love hate
relationship with this game though I I
said multiple times that I love
blood-borne well I can't say I love love
war more than just but I like
blood-borne just overall more than this
game I love this game is this your
number one now that's tough blood-borne
is really high up there okay but I
really like the way this plays some kind
of a whole lot I don't know I just
something something about blood one for
me was just yeah this is a great first
shot yeah they definitely have a couple
very just like wallpaper II like there
we go let me just stop and soak up the
machines here an atmosphere does
everything carry over a hundred percent
on you game plus Noctis it does look
like that the prayer beads that he had
transferred over and his prosthetics
were his prayer beads that he had
accumulated prior carried over so I
wonder if you've done more prayer be
like does that double like I would
assume you've got to be able to get some
now we're gonna go find a mini boss that
has the first pair of bead I think the
only thing that hat oh no my gourd
season is over I saw those earlier
they're just grayed out because they're
like oh you can't use them yet but I'm
assuming you can't get more I think ten
is the max but it this is a New Game+ is
a chance for you to get any seeds that
you missed if you did miss them John
Luke actually put up a guide yesterday
for the nine gourd seeds so you know
some are pretty straightforward some
aren't I missed one that somehow I got
the my first playthrough but my first
playthrough I'm it's there if you need
it long story short have a ceramic sharp
did you ever use that stuff I never use
the ceramic cards or the Fistful of ash
works against bosses oh really
yeah does it like this morning at them
yeah they like and then you can get
behind them and do some hits oh my god I
fight like an honor abortion Oh actually
maybe not really honorable they do
whatever the hell they want they do
whatever oh my god
oh you look like a lucky thing the
damage is real man that's gamespy's he
had the blood cloud skills show it
please if you can
he's got to have it the ball you can
beat about yeah it's a really quick I
got it smoke yeah blow smoke I bet you
you're missing one ninjutsu I'll
probably you can fight them what right
the twin that the two of them I did I
didn't beat him okay I didn't realize
that was a you know husband wife by the
way okay sense that make sense right
yeah
and that's where I'll stop for that one
for you guys that's a side boss that I
was talking about a parent that's like a
side boss there's like two that I know
of there are like two side boss well
kind of three a lot of people can beat
SEC euro but cannot be blood-borne
oh is that just like something your
where's the this information coming from
Noctis I could see why a second row
could be harder though only because
sometimes to defeat some of these bosses
it's about your ability to deflect and
parry which obviously wasn't in
blood-borne and blood-borne is a lot of
like dodging doing damage so I could see
that in some ways how long was your
first playthrough Oh forty three hours
damn 43 it took me about eight hours to
be the follow-up I it took me 6 I think
my wall okay so it's not fair actually
to you took for me to say that one
because you might play through second
time dipped through really quickly you
ran through stuff you were telling me
how you you were like speeding through
the second half of the game your first
playthrough uh yeah my first playthrough
yeah so so if it's hard for me to give
you a true number because my first
playthrough I got the short ending which
skips a lot that's why I said don't pick
the the choice I did other the other
than for the achievement basically you
lose out on an entire area I'll just say
that that's not too spoilery I think um
basically I'm trying to save you from
hurting yourself like I did
anyways I the second time around
I was able to do things faster and so my
second playthrough I feel like I'm at 33
ish hours and I've done most stuff in
the second playthrough however because I
had knowledge of like 70% of the game or
80% of the game I went through a lot of
that stuff quicker and so I couldn't
really tell you outside of like my
actual first experience how long it was
it like my first playthrough was really
fast I was like twenty two hours or
something like that but that's because I
ran through a lot of stuff in like
trouble and then I also did the short
ending which again skips an area which
that area is pretty substantial and it's
probably another like five hours if not
more I don't know what do you think last
area oh yeah Oh actually you know what
it's not even just the last area because
there's more after that yeah there's
more after that there's multiple boss
fights yeah so I'm gonna guess like five
to seven there yeah so I don't know I
think it's like a like a 35 Plus hour
game depending on how like what you do
and it could be as short as like well
people are speed running it now
obviously but life's game is your first
playthrough variations to it that are
pretty insane like I already came in my
brain like okay like if I was to try and
speed run it mm-hmm like just to get to
an ending like you could skip that that
that that yeah yeah like like to get to
that the the fastest speedrun ending
would be like what I did which is like
you just cut your game short you don't
do that entire last area you don't even
like get all the stuff that like
basically you're gonna eventually get
stuff for you know your master and that
takes you down to birth paths like you
don't even have to get
all that stuff that you don't want to
also for those that don't know I'm gonna
have John Luke show you where the
freaking first bite oh wow hey
firecracker is that guy just did 70
percent holy [ __ ] New Game+ ain't
messing around oh okay oh you got all
your revives what the hell okay so do
you get an extra Levi maybe it's an
extra one maybe they are like you know
what we're gonna give you an extra
revive because it's so hard or maybe you
turn on hardmode [ __ ] yeah maybe it's
just like the game's tougher yeah maybe
I just maybe you just ramped up the
difficulty maybe they'd like the
equivalent of the demon belt like what
if you get demon Bell Plus that what
you're going through right now we could
try it anyway yikes
that was rough no so I totally it's not
resurrection based I think it's just I
think you turn on at well what's that
whatever that bottom left in the icon is
I don't know what that means
it's probably like do you want to take
more damage it's probably just like hey
this game is way harder yep that's what
it is ref I sell is to use the axe on
high is it good so maybe just makes the
game extra hard question mark I didn't
know like that's crazy I gotta send this
a sec Eero slack yeah yeah I'm wondering
if that's just like it makes it harder I
assume do I see Carter's resurrection I
assumed it was a lot of rhetoric thing
so like that seems like the kind of
[ __ ] you would like people would
want to do like I want to do a new
resurrection but I guess not
yeah I'll try the accident okay right
damn that guy's alliterated me
yeah a little follow-up oh I just
unlocked at level four ability I want to
mess around with that okay it's all
right
the trade the trade trades are not as
valuable in this game as yeah that's
always hidden stuff you oh my god you're
taking damage on top of the defy way
really yes I'm gonna watch you go yeah
you're taking damage hold on perfect
defects
yeah on blocks you're taking down all
right so basically if I did I think you
don't perfect parry you're just eating
Danny
yep
yeah okay see on your perfect parry
there you did not take damage but on
those other mousse that oh don't um do
that okay good I'm just staring at his
health bar right now
that's alright
safety first oh you want a little bag
where have you seen that when you do
like the different other executions
there's like different the jumping way
good job where you like spin him around
he does like a hurricane Radha the
mercury counter ones pretty good yeah
yeah yeah I like doing that one dan
Murray on you game plus a lot of damage
- yeah Mario I did not get any prayer
beads from him yeah okay so you do not
get extra prayer beads so you think
there's a finite amount then I think
there aren't okay I need this a finite
amount or at least you don't get like
the same ones I imagine the work yeah
the ones you're missing okay so like
you're not getting more life which is
interesting because like in Souls games
and even blood-borne right like you
could keep leveling right it's possible
they maybe add new prayer beads another
spots but at least like the ones that
were that one that was there in the
original area yeah this is insane though
that blocks that if you don't deflect
properly in this war we're gonna call as
ultra hard mode even though I'm just
making that term up it actually does
damage which is nutty because that means
like certain bosses like most people
seem gonna cheer Oh probably at this
point or like you know about him like he
does like one where he does like a
flurry of attacks like six attacks or
something like that which means if you
don't actually that makes a lot of sense
some in my mind because I always felt
like in even some cases for myself I I
kind of like know that I can kind of
spam it a little bit in some cases right
because you're not worried about
perfectly deflecting all of them you're
just hoping that you have some rhythm to
it where you can deflect it and that you
deflect most of them right but now if
you're going to take
yeah but it sounds like you can Mike you
probably could turn it off too so if you
don't want this experience don't do it
it seems like you're given the option to
turn it on at the beginning yeah the
very beginning and then it gives you the
option to turn it off once you turn it
off you can't turn it back on though yes
like but I'm curious if if I didn't turn
it on in the first place did that guy
give me a chance to turn it off lallan
uh-hmm but it seems like they give you
an out yeah I regret it
oh you know I haven't watching on these
guys if walking beauty damage you block
one church yup
holy smokes even the normal enemies yike
Arun there Perry are there prior to I
would say I would have to like go back
and compare but I definitely feels like
when will hob do a zero hit run
who knows max belt who's it you never
know could happen
hit run will definitely happen I mean
there's that guy he just did the there's
a guy he just did the all five games in
a row yeah that's hot yeah the top yeah
yeah but I'm sure he'll do one
eventually like normal I think if he
gets the timing right for like just like
your first way through it I think you
could do it listen that sucks
do you know hit oh you know what this
game would actually be significantly
harder to do a no hit alright well I
feel like in some cases yes because you
have to deflect a lot more attacks right
than you do in other games because it's
posture based yeah so the risk the risk
is higher rather instead of like in in
the in the other souls wardens games you
can kind of like you know dodge a lot of
the attacks and then kind of like get
your damage in I you can technically
still do that against most bosses there
are some bosses where they're just built
on the on the deflect mechanic so you
can't just do that
this is sucky ro Hardin hood we got
suckered yeah at second rows shadows die
thrice well I mean technically we can
die through huh
certain cases depending on how you look
depending on high order yeah like you
can die in three phases alright so if
you guys didn't know and most people
probably didn't on your first
playthrough because every one of us
missed this vendor we're gonna show you
one of the most important vendors in
this early game you don't you cannot I
cannot understand how much the
firecrackers help you in this early part
of the game and there is a vendor you
can buy them from that will help you on
multiple like mini bosses here before
you could actually where I actually
thought you could buy it which is after
gyobu I actually don't know where he is
okay I'll show it to you it's it's a
little bit right before the the cannon
guy coming up here cool SEC euro shadows
a lot this is true oh this is the cannon
guy okay so look to your left so go up
there now jump back
yep jump back that way get up to that
and then get up to that next little
ledge up here and then look up to your
right now go up there and that is this
is where there is your first merchants
and the firecrackers like this like the
Firecracker oil he's not selling it
already there you go see it would be
here if I this is a game changer you
must buy the firecrackers I went through
my entire first playthrough without even
having the firecrackers a lot of stuff I
was a fool cool um firecrackers are
really good they work against bosses
they work if we had this enemies they
they just in general buy you time I've
started using it to heal at some points
what does shadows die twice even mean
you're a shadow and you can die more
than once because you can come back to
life are you gonna legend
no yeah you can definitely get him I was
just wondering if you're gonna do with
the different execution edge that was
pretty cool too because he stabs you
from the front and just like tosses you
off them English voice acting there is
full English audio but I would never do
it if I had the option of their Japanese
it's pretty good language everything so
I kinda wanna try it out if you want to
you can maybe next a point it goes in a
minute that's not that hard just go to
options and then quit out and come back
in you see an Activision logo yeah you
know he's he's seen now he's beginning
to believe that's the thing is uh we
were doing that guy cutting the guide
mm-hmm
I was trying to I only showed footage
from sort of the early parts yeah yeah
but that's what we're learning right
that's what I was learning so it's like
all the tips we had I was like like I
suck though like I know I know you feel
well because you don't know what you're
not the muscle memory for you you don't
know half like a lot of these games the
first time is like trying to understand
enemy types move mechanics what's safe
what's not safe and so you play end up
playing like super cautious and if you
think about it on top of all of that
like the game is just different
like fundamentally and so like all the
things you thought you knew like nope
man like I wouldn't say all but a lot of
the stuff you thought you knew and like
could just apply they don't mostly work
some stuff works for sure but not not
everything I didn't even go this way
I kind of remember this path but I
definitely did not go this way this is
that the idol like right above here yeah
I think's right here or what yes right
there yeah
just get all around those people no
Battle Royale not good enough oh man am
i gay am I gonna go after the Mario
manases I kind of like the English voice
it's not bad but I don't like to always
pay attention to those subtitles that's
fair switch there area lots of secrets
to this game yeah there's a lot of
secrets Leslie there's a a bunch of
stuff to be discovered there's a lot of
side mini-bosses that you can fight like
I had mentioned the headless earlier
there's five of them that I know of and
each one gives you a different one of
those candies to permanently use with
your your emblems spirit emblems which
is pretty cool yeah you have to go to
language there's a specific setting so
let's switch it to English
ah okay
I'm now playing with English view
damn could you imagine like turning this
on and then like thinking like I don't
need the I I'm glad they gave you a
second out but could you imagine like
not being able to turn it off and go
like this is too hard I guess I'll start
another saying I think that's why they
gave you the hours like they dodged the
Tengu yet what does that even mean Bob
check out one of these boys
[Music]
I'm out
okay
there you are
what's up dude
all right uh okay I'm gonna draw him
over here and then all oh maybe I can do
it still
oh I don't even see you on K Jim I've
been like talking in this giant cage
didn't kill the other guy than hid sick
get the free back he said all right
let's I think that oh you can claim
Bentham even though yeah well you get
burned in the people's elbow hello
someone guess I guess that he's grabbing
the head smashes like a hundred percent
dead turbo dead date with some would say
alright oh he was about to do it again
yeah I found that sticking close to him
better because you can dodge that and
then dodge is like short grab oh great
block actually well did you actually
deflect back yeah could even take damage
yeah it just looks it looks like again
like fully parry it or whatever you
wanna call yeah suck it you can even
grab that stupid thing
cause I'm his uh whatever the hell that
thing is of a wooden plank
[Applause]
yeah a little there yep he just wants
hug she just likes giving hugs yeah oh
you know what you whatever I'm not gonna
even entertain sweet justice
yeah you're good
[Music]
so this guy was a real pain in the ass
the first time now he's a joke but you
know that's that's kind of the case in
most attack when you're playing these
the second time around that's true on
the new game mode I like to suffer what
can I say so that's gonna be the updated
version is this like ninja gaiden it's
really ten shoes like ten shoes why
can't you you can plus already damn you
waste no time uh he okay to preface this
we were lucky we had the game early sure
so it helps us kind of get through the
game faster oh that's the that's the
door that you can open from the demon
Bell side you can go up there so this is
where the gourd seed would be I'm
wondering what's here instead divine
grab I know when you use those but those
give you a hundred percent HP back I
think if I read that crawl this guy's
tough oh yeah I use a PC well you could
clear out everything and there's like
there's a there's the idol down there if
you just want to run down there yeah I
want to try and beat him though oh no no
I know I'm just saying you could run
down there to get the idol and then
makes it easier to stealth kill a lot of
these guys thing down I woke him up many
times like on the stream and I was like
dude how oh you forgot about the pot guy
whose job is only to alert to everyone
and it's very annoying
yikes
oh the explosive flying engine yeah that
guy's just has a battlecry and you're
like what the hell happened there's been
a lot of good memes about that guy he
just comes out of nowhere because he's
on a shinobi kite so what I didn't even
see the cut like I see a lot of people
like to see him coming yeah I never saw
I was just running and then all of a
sudden I just got just like you just
come like a dive bomber all of a sudden
and just what cba
jaws says I think again plus will be a
cakewalk with all the tools um if you
don't want it to be a cakewalk turn on
this super hard mode or whatever the
hell this is where I feel like it's
worse than the demon Bell because I if
you just joined the stream like watch
when he fights this warlord I'm always
wrong I'm gonna guess that John Luke
gets hit once and you're gonna see just
how much damage you take with that this
mode on I don't even know what to call
it I just look at the bottom-left icon
you can see it in the in the beginning
of the game curl gave us a charm
we gave it back to him luckily the game
decides to give you one more chance like
hey do you are you really sure you want
to like suffer and like put yourself
through this and so at least you have a
way out if you don't want to experience
this because everything seems to hurt
way more I don't know we'll find out
later maybe but like even when you don't
parry correctly and you're blocking
blocking you soak damage as well
and so it made it exponentially harder
we thought it was a revive thing but
it's not so I think it's just difficulty
I think it's just scaling the difficulty
way higher like even this grunt his
posture is not breaking normally four
hits five hits maybe and normal he would
probably already
gunso ready to stagger it's almost like
smarter AI it's almost no one can rise
me up without the leveling up is god of
war super heart mode where the enemies
will get smarter and stronger right kind
of is this more difficult than Dark
Souls huh I mean so dark it was proper
or like I mean later like the more
recent games
oh really a matter of perspective is
sort of what I've realized as I see
people who play Dark Souls I'm like dang
this games like definitely from
somewhere yes game I've seen other
people who are like oh I no problem no
problem
we're like I've you know not a huge Dark
Souls fan I was yeah figured this game
out to each their own
probably difficulty is always in the
like your mileage may vary I mean it's
it's the same thing as when you talk
about a blood-borne boss with someone
and you're like ah that wasn't that guy
was easy but then if they're super hard
for you but then you have someone that
you fight that's super easy for you
that's hard for someone else so I think
it's all like relative does this game
less class variety I mean there's a lot
of skills yeah I haven't even
incorporated a lot of those skills into
my attacks and stuff well so how long is
gameplay says Trevor to you I think it's
a thirty foot five plus our game it
could be forty plus or more than forty
five depending on if you do everything
because even John Luke who you know was
very careful he combed through
everything and he he had just beaten the
game he's still one shot do you
resurrect yeah you resurrect there's so
for those of you that don't know about
dragon rod or curious about dragon rod
it matter if it happens on revive or
resurrect so it doesn't matter you're
better off almost always resurrect so
lots of things that only happens on
per-minute deaths Oh No
that's that can't antibodies that can't
be true I am
also I immediately died okay okay you
know why I say that yeah because I my
first playthrough I was telling everyone
in the office is like I'm not gonna
resurrect I'm gonna go through this game
because I thought resurrect was the
mechanic that was tied to dragon Ron
right like if you resurrect the dragon
rot would happen sooner a quicker etc
right so I would I would let bump or die
right and so does that count as a
permanent no no it's the opposite it's
right bumper dying is a permanent death
no that's right foot right Brett right
bumper or lays yeah yeah left bumper
dies apparent death and that will get
you dragon rot if you only resurrect but
never die and have to go back at point
you'll never get dragon okay gotcha so
it's just actual death like hermit death
okay over death then that makes sense
then that is that is correct because I
was insane like I was trying to not
resurrect whereas you should be
resurrected should be resurrect because
it doesn't are you sure resurrect
doesn't spread dragon out though that's
what body said and but I believe it
because also the only time you get it's
a resurrect as you get the dragon rock
is when you die after I after yeah okay
okay yeah yeah okay I never die like
that's so weird though to me because you
would think the resurrection mechanic
would have a negative effect it should
have a negative effect in my mind
because like you're basically cheating
death or you've technically died already
can you finish the game skipping some
bosses yes you could skip a lot of stuff
it's like the speed runs out there so
far like that's pretty nutty and they
only do like I don't know look like 12
boss we are playing on PC right now the
gate this game has three endings you're
wrong my dude there's four it's four
onions which makes it tough when you
didn't permit it's like some major
endings and then one ending that's like
a variation but requires you to do a lot
of different things yeah there's there's
two that require you to do specific
things and then two that are just tied
to a decision
is that correct right to two of the four
endings are decided by a decision sure
right and then the other two you
actually have to do things to trigger it
but you need to do specific steps to
trigger yes I get unseen aid all the
time well then your Gd lucky because
it's a 30% chance unless you have that's
with no Dragon ROG so although I have
had it where I've had really low unseen
aid and it just happened so
yeah anything's technically possible I'm
gonna give this guy another shot I think
you can do I am awesome but I don't want
you to have to sacrifice the charm thing
I am curious like I'm just curious if
like the whole block damage thing goes
away and the whole like this insane idea
like those guys are just normal enemies
and they're doing 30% ishizawa like
damage to is this better than me oh um
their difference
I liked me oh I thought that I thought
neo is a little bit long for me though
like again all the story is super long
that game is like a 60 to 80 our first
playthrough kind of game I think this
which is nutty yeah I I think so too but
I mean if you really want all that then
yes yeah it's gonna be a neo - it must
have been good enough for them to make a
neo - right so yeah with Geralt of Rivia
can you get the demons oh I think she
has it you probably can't get another
one but I'm gonna try it dude should you
uh what if you did demon fell on top of
it I think that's what I'm gonna try I
want to know all right so this has
become like a testing oh my god yep neo
is pretty grinding because like me arrow
like levels like they kind of gated you
in some way it's like you could out
skill certain areas but it definitely
was easier if you had more I was like
way more RP to leave oh yeah it's true
yes like that was not super into that
because I was like oh I did like being
able to do fashion Souls though yeah
this is the one thing I'm sad about
psyche Row is that you can't do any
fashion
and you're mainly like the only thing
that changes really is the skills and
your prosthetics but you're using a
sword almost like the entire time it's
one of those guys it's like I'm gonna
just back step by the way you can't get
me someone someone's here right mmm I
sense Dean turn around man what's up
what's wrong why'd you turn it around
immediately saw me that's okay if I can
just get him over here I just don't want
the other guy then so you get on scene
eight in new game+ I think so we have to
get it just now yeah fifteen percent set
because you died once right I think the
skulls already has dragon roar whatever
please he can live through it he's fine
he's good that guy's a tame come on man
come on I see antihero saying the same
thing f
I've been choosing the die because I
thought reviving will give you more drag
arad know so apparently it's just the
hard death so that's actually speeding
it up if anything by not resurrecting
such an so that's actually pretty funny
I don't know I don't know if that's in
our us guy is like not letting you just
got a pair Ian he's got a Batum
but I can break this guy
we got every over there yeah
I love when you go back through a game
and you see like yep oh I know that area
better it sucks whoa I thought I found
you a sec you stop mini-bosses twice for
only once only once if you go back into
stealth they get all their life back so
that's to prevent you from just cheese
in it where is he
do I beat this game a third time don't
leak I really don't want to I really
want that other ending I really want
that other end take a break in a picture
later yeah I got to do a while it's
fresh and the memories there my muscle
memory maybe I new game+ there I don't
know are there new enemies slash count
of them or bosses in new game+ don't
know we just literally started
everything has been the same yeah
although this guy's pretty small right
yeah this guy got me left will turn out
to be wise I'm not doing this without
that free here mr. big weather 95 says
basically always reg and res and then
get the eff out or get good yep it's
true not too far in the game so I'll
butterfly ya butterfly is a she's tough
and she's one of the kind of first
bosses you know true bosses you
experience I think if you go that path I
went the other way
which I think I put myself in a way
tougher hole I would tell I wouldn't I
would say not that you have to do this
because like it's open and you can go
whichever way you want but I think after
you kind of open up some of the castle
you're probably better off going to
Hirata because I think difficulty there
is pretty moderate and you get a lot of
prosthetics there and you'll get some
you know nice upgrades and things like
that before kind of finalizing the
castle whereas for me I kind of like
finalized the castle and alright I went
and finished the castle first because I
was like cool I'm gonna finish like one
area first and then
come back to it come back to Hirata and
like yeah that was a mistake because
basically I fought another boss and I
feel like he's harder than butterfly but
whatever anyone else play firestorm are
only on the shooting mister only on the
scene yesterday crime I'm sure Dave
Jewett was he playing a bunch more
firestorm if he wasn't sick he's like
super sick right now dude I watched Oh
Dave's fire fun gameplay and oh my god
he he is a sick game remove the uppercut
I can't remember if you could do
everything
can you remember if general Tenzin gave
that uppercut
oh it doesn't matter what he does now
man now you gotta believe oh all right I
like that you tried I like the Oh did
you try cuz I look like he tried no I
tried did he have this upward slash I
cannot remember to be honest it's a long
do this is rough should I go get the
demon Bell I don't want to like just
hammer my head on this guy let's make it
tougher oh I was gonna say do you really
want to get the demon Bell and make it
harder I just want to know okay I want
to know for science man I want to know
how tough this game can be
oh dude can you imagine fighting the
headless with this uh this debuff I have
right now no way
all right let's do it let's ring this
Bell ring that Bell
alright if you guys didn't know we're
heading to a sort of secret area oh you
think the Headless is there probably
right oh he is what do you think he lets
go say like fighting him with this
debuff no way man are you kidding
that'd be brutal you have divine
confetti that would be all right don't
do it
you think it's down there the old butt
hole snatcher he has a thing for blood
holds that guy come on show up right
behind him I'm at a castle I'm stuck at
the Raging Bull yeah so big grin protip
you used them firecrackers on him he
hates the firecrackers like hates it if
you didn't get the firecrackers yet
you're you probably passed gyobu because
you're in the castle so just go to the
the vendor that's right passing yo boo
and you'll get yourself why it's
interesting how'd you get that Co oh
those guys you can just jump into this
instant kill on them I did not know that
in fact Wow okay alright that is the
difficulty of this game is epic yeah
well we found a way to make it a
question do you think speedrunners could
use this bell to somehow like they don't
even know but member when we were
watching a speedrun yesterday they just
skip tempo completely that's true you
probably don't even need something we
just skip some phones on what kind of
run you're doing you know what I mean
like it all boss run maybe this is
somehow useful I don't know I can
already say maybe let's redo all memory
one I think you can beat him with the
confetti yeah I just don't know how much
damage he does that's the thing
are you like is it already on no
sinister burden it doesn't give you an
extra icon maybe not you mean Bell
around yes yeah no I know you have it
now oh right man let's do it
double whammy what do what you're gonna
fight the Headless oh okay you can't
open that door just use the idol oh
that's why I was like wait you're gonna
go fight them do you get unlimited
firecrackers I mean you have as much as
you have spirit emblems and you have
ways to increase your spirit emblem per
skill tree the other pro tip I think
I'll just give credit to his body I
think is you just buy them early on
because they only cost like 10 gold per
so like you know if you're about to
fight a boss or some guy that you know
you're gonna struggle with and you have
a bunch of gold either by moneybags or
just buy a bunch of spirit emblems then
you have them like for the rest of the
game they're also just pretty useful to
have oh you're my master gave accesed
you I'm not telling you to trust me the
gourd of medicine that was originally
I'm a doctor
yes but it seems he entrusted into your
sure you may have the medicinal walk
even after yes is there a way to improve
it bring me good seeds yes medicinal
adding new see if you find anymore right
no can't upgrade it further let's do uh
[Music]
no will do will do the estate that's a
good way to test out how brutal this is
oh you're gonna go Hirata yeah I think
that's actually that's a good call
that's a good yeah john monahan
asking what debuff are you referring to
so in new game+ once you get to Kuro
Kuro gives you a charm you can then
decide to keep the charm or give it back
to them if you give it back to him it
seems like you turn on a like super hard
mode or it feels like it turns on a
super hard mode where what we it's hard
for me to say that for sure because we
haven't tried it without the charm
because it's it's a thing that you
excuse three applause for not sure yeah
you do get to turn off but if you turn
it off you can't turn it back on and so
we're trying to play with it as much as
we can before turning it off to see what
the effects are so far we know that or
feels like damage enemy or an enemy
damage is way higher than normal like
the warlord slash in one case was one
shotting or doing like 75% the other
thing that's interesting is and we don't
know if this is a New Game+ mechanic or
the lack of charm mechanic is that if
you don't deflect an attack properly and
you only block it you actually take
damage still just not as much damage
which never happened in non new game so
I'm not sure if that's the debuff that
from the lack of the charm from Kuro or
if it's just new game+ my guess is it's
the debuff now we've turned on the demon
bell on top of the supposed debuff by
not having to Roshan
so we'll see how that goes also can't
tell again if it's the debuff or not but
some of the enemies seem to have like
way more posture and seem a little bit
smarter that seem fair
yeah I'd say they're definitely more
reserved like like the one hat guy that
you're low one kind of like samurai guy
that you fight that has a hat usually
after two swings he likes to rebuttal
with a swing at least from what I know
pattern wise in this case John Luke has
attacked him four or five times and he
blocked all of them and it like did like
20% posture at best off for swings and
that guy would normally probably lose
posture by four hits in in a normal game
so as mentioned that yes crime has said
to Ramses but yes the hope is that the
review proper is today is what I I heard
a cynical saying I playing now this game
is no joke yeah it's it's definitely
tough for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
so if you guys didn't know about this
vendor at Hirata there's a guy in a
little pot he will take treasure carp
scales from you and sell you stuff he
has a couple good things
he's got the burn board or the anti burn
gourd
[Music]
I said yeah the withering Gorder yeah so
it keeps all the stuff I already got
this floating
oh you rich but I know why you're rich
oh yeah I see so there's a second guy
yeah I did not know that I didn't I need
to show you where that guy was I don't
know I I gotta learn more about the full
dragon mask because like I said I think
you can gain power by paying with your
like experience I think instead of your
memories
oh come on
all right
so sorry headphone users i would expect
firecrackers to be that loud do you keep
everything in your game plus yes it
seems like everything everything
everything's good even the prayer beads
for new game+ is it's very difficult if
not maybe impossible i don't know to get
all the skills your first time through
that's true for every man experience
perspective yeah I mean especially cuz
you just not very good so you're not
gonna guess I also but if you can carry
them over it seems like you have a
better chance of like actually getting
all the skills I'm also curious as I was
telling you before I wonder if some of
the later game prosthetics in the skill
tree that you can upgrade are tied to
items that you can only get in new game+
I say that because like for example the
whistle the it needs like a ring like a
specific ring item that is part of the
upgrade tree and I did not find that
item my first playthrough and even my
second playthrough unless I missed it
which is very possible I think that
would be cool if there's like some later
game stuff that you would have to play
new game+ to get but i don't know the
ability from the fish hand is pretty
cool it's like a crazy combo slide I've
never actually tried it look at air
combo or something there's five oh no
where is that one from the fourth one
temple arts yeah where the hell was that
from I never had I never had the simple
arts no wonder Tamar was talking about
Oh God the more you know I went through
the first game without the Hasina text
I should buy some stuff sounds cool no
there is floating passage that's when I
just got oh I need simple Oh
do you know what this is I think this is
the move that uh yeah can Ichiro can do
so that and then okay dude there's so
much stuff you can miss like really
easily yeah yeah okay
was it the green monk guy that I'd never
seen you never saw the green monk I and
that's because you did a boss before
that before that and I did after okay so
did he give you the text he gave me a
text to give to the whip to the girls
okay that's the holy chapter invested so
he didn't get that you didn't get the
arts from him though you didn't get this
text from him do you remember where you
got the text from ooo the the simple
yeah yeah I gotta get that
Oh
so so far the demon bells how do I make
it through the whole game without a
whole set of skills
I'm which I'm trash literal trash chat
that is not build any more any posture
despite five swings which one's better
Sakura go [ __ ] shooting that wall you
know one game's not even out so how
would you like him to judge that one too
much of a difference with the demon
granted yeah I thought he was saying how
while the other enemies are the normal
enemies are technically harder he said
it didn't feel like yeah compared to the
boss of losses my controller stopped
working for a sec hold on that's not my
fault
that was the controller you it could
have been your fault cause you could
have nudged it out of the I thought my
ingame it's in a pagoda on the top of
sash cave you went through where you're
like hey that one guy well yeah yeah if
you keep going up that cave there's you
can go up yeah dude yes there's a little
area above it hey you know what it's
okay Chad he didn't know about the first
merchant there's that at least I have
that yeah Marco just make sure if you
use the snake stuff use it before you
get to a certain point at the end
because I got to the end before knowing
about that stuff and then I couldn't
trigger when that triggers one of its
secret endings yeah you get an option
for the ending yeah that's what triggers
it and you have to do it you should do
it a little bit earlier when you can I
bet goes tissue semen came out and Eric
skipped it alright yeah anyone know
where the text is that you get yeah
Marco do you have the me blue breathing
technique yet if you don't you need that
to get it it's either one of two things
you either it got it from the he was
blocking with nothing the whole time
you're that you either got it from the
monk ish guy that I was talking about in
a green garb or if you didn't talk to
him like I didn't in two playthroughs
it's in the water in tempo but you need
breathing technology or I don't know I
call it the technology technique to be
able to do it so I can tell you where it
is though it's pretty straightforward
that doesn't work anymore in this mode
ya know your spam block the spam block
is no good your spam block is no good
here that was the tip watching games
like by the way you can totally do this
and it's like knotting this knot with
this yeah Marco I like I said if you can
die for it I can tell you where it is
but if you can't die for it yet then you
need to do something to get that oh you
do have it okay it's um crap I'd have to
look at the the list of the travel idols
but it's um I think it's like one before
the inner sanctum and then it's like
down a hill and in a pond like right
below it right below the idol that I'm
talking about
so I like literally right below but it's
like like south of G Idol guys are drunk
off second oh there's four of them now
who is this monkey he's like you you
would either have saw him cuz it's very
noticeable if you saw him cuz I write
when I saw it on John Luke you knows
like who the hell is that
he's like oh I've been talking this guy
this whole time like Oh sick I go I've
not seen this guy twice but like you
said do you know which boss it is that I
killed that that's so weird though why
though like why is that the case though
is there a reason my guess is because uh
it's triggers like another state hears
noise because after you beat him and you
talk to Kuro you get like your next
objective yeah which is to go there and
I think that's what triggered because um
two more also beat him and then went
there and he met the guy but I think
it's because he didn't talk to he
definitely did because he was like I
don't want to make this decision I was
like dude they force you to me I think
the ideas didn't go there and do that
before they like sorry Marco not inner
sanctum the whatever the one with the
great the Big Buddha is like look for
the cheap throws oil look for the one
Idol that's above that one I can't
remember the names if you tell if you
list to me the idols that are in tempo
like in the middle part of it I can tell
you which one it exactly is I just can't
remember off the top of my head the
exact naming of it oh man this fire so
warm sock guys so good
ah he painted for him who betray the bad
trades
yeah this this spot can definitely take
a minute if you want to sell to too many
dog shows and people yeah it's red yeah
you could also google it Marco would be
maybe faster than you telling this is
just be careful spoilers
shugendo not shugendo yeah they just
replace it with like I don't know yeah
so far the diamond Bell hasn't been
making things do much harder it's
whatever we turned on the first time
right yeah like that's really like the
tough thing I feel like I'm sure it'll
make the boss
mom dude what's up yeah they try to
blind you it's it might be temple
grounds I yeah none of people have this
guy I don't have this guy I'm gonna find
you in my next playthrough green guy
yeah I think it's a simple esoteric text
son of a garbage all right I don't get
that too I know that's why I wore was
like so high he's like dude this temple
was so sick and I was like oh you're
talking about the enemies there they're
pretty cool and it's like no he was
talking about actually being able to
wear the axes yeah so so far it just
seems like they replace all of like
where the items normally are with like
just like random stuff
hey what up what's the gigantic snake
happening when is a gigantic snake
coming up we technically just were in
that area but we're just messing around
with the demon Bell with I think I think
for sure that Kuro charm thing is like
worse way worse than the Bell yep if
that's the case then maybe just yeah
like you said like you just try you just
turn the Bell on for like when you're
clearing mobs and trash and then you
just turn it off for the boss yeah
crimes is Resident Evil 2 DMC five
Secura what year is this
I know the the one year with breath of
the wild that was a crazy year - I think
right
Oh what even seem that useful
he doesn't care nothing is better so far
for me than well because I haven't used
all the skills book that the each Imam
strike or whatever is like the best one
yeah you get posture back they get more
posture damage to them like seems so so
it's apparently I got the double so yeah
it's just part of it I've never done
shadow rush shadow rush is cool
it goes like through right or something
yeah and then you you can use the
spirits to do like a follow-up jonathan
john monahan if you want to make the
guys with the hats which annoyed the
[ __ ] out of me easier you get this axe
and they are a joke you literally smash
through their hat and get a follow up
and it's easy as that i did not have the
axe when I fought them the first time
and boy was it a pain in the butt
a lot of the enemies usually have a
weakness to a prosthetic unless it's
like this guy who doesn't matter like
he's weak to everything
yes mr. big brother I think or do you
have to ring the bell each time to
activate it I know they make disable I
know you disable it you can just say
with it I don't know if you have to ring
the bell each time I don't know if you
have you might have to go back okay well
I mean it's not that bad cuz there's an
idol there so you could be faster I'm
just a shackle to it you can't even set
it as like your homeward bound listen we
go the simple art ooh
alright here's gonna be a good challenge
oh the spear guy spear boy well you got
to kill all his buddies first right he
wrecked me twice on stream because I
kept not being able to make URI I can't
do it to save my life
so instead I just Circle dodged a lot of
his like perilous attacks and then got
my hits in his posture well at least in
normal is pretty shitty though so yeah
it's pretty easy to get the problem is
like maybe not in this mode you get one
shot you could get one shot at me get
one shot I am because I'm not playing
all right guys
yeah okay so yeah probably at the fast
rocket itself but yeah
I'll beat this guy and then I'm gonna go
turn the I'm gonna go turn it off okay
so that's good we have a bow I want to
see the difference yeah then you can go
if I pay a warlord guy yeah I was if see
if his uppercut slash exists see if it
like does like as much damage the
uppercut slash ISM maybe a New Game+
thing that's my guess
okay so you think it may be just like
one extra like moveset to kind of throw
you off throw them off there since about
Dark Souls would work they'll like add
an extra moon set or something what was
that even I saw nothing
oh wait there's another hat guy it's a
big hat guy what's a what's a big hat
guy with blades at the temple there's
another there's other guys with hats
talk about the spinning boots uh they
know John don't use that on that guy
talk about the drill guy that guy sucks
I hate / if it was just one of them it's
not bad but they're always in pairs I
don't know why sorry you just stop them
I don't think the hats gonna help you
but I thought you're talking about small
hat guys um to be honest those guys I
either singled out somehow or like I
avoided them cuz I just never wanted to
deal with them they're super annoying
I apologize that's I'm forgot those guys
had hats there are other guys with hats
later but they're rare like they're
different you would have like said
something to help me distinguish
[Music]
sometimes you doesn't read that it's the
runaway is enough basically you just
want to see their name go away and then
you're like they said maybe you can't
reset as easily a new game I don't even
know because like by now you would have
stopped for me what
oh it's just sometimes begin those that
sneaky sneaky
okay I'm gonna truth here's the free one
how did you like it
shinobi hunter in chin of muni sin did
you try I'm not good at mercury coming
anything yeah see that's what I did to
them to you I just stepped god no tough
though he's doing a lot of damage yeah
the 75% is sweep I messed up yeah a
little stabby this guy sucks though
I'm yeah that's alright
check every counter man I'm not good at
mercury care that's why that's why I
think my if I went if and when I decided
to go through it again
I will definitely be forcing myself to
me period here we go I think I'd do it
too early and I always get punished yeah
cuz it's window the strike is supposed
to land and I always dime trying to
pre-emptive also it doesn't help that
like the game kind of like got me into
like the shitty deflecting hammer your
attic guards so I got a pelleted see
this is what sucks though now you got to
rebuild all that posture any beginner
tips for a new guy oh there's a bunch we
have a beginner's tips video Adrian so
check that out I would also say you know
part of its just learning the game like
being able to persevere like you'll get
better over time that's what happens in
these kind of games get stabbed all
right do we want to for the purposes of
just let's let's remove you're gonna
remove the suffering that we were trying
to endure this last hour and 20 minute
difference now and you're still
recording right so at least we'll have
it yeah okay so let's get rid of the
demon bowel
so that's gone and let's travel to
Temple are you gonna turn off the bell I
turn off the bell - okay oh you're
dilapidated sorry the dilapidated temple
alright
sculptor give me give us a good stuff
give us a charm so weird hearing English
take his charm back additional hardship
that must be what it is cuz it said it
was you couldn't go back on it
can you speedrun the game people have
been speedrunning it for sure but I want
to try and speedrun it sometime alright
let's rest up let's go fight that
warlord and that maybe we'll be where we
in the stream unless you want to kill
the spear guy for some reason let's go
to that warlord outskirts right stairway
to heaven see you should've got that
other thing a little snake Idol ah I won
right before it that's true
alright let's see how much this changes
yeah alright I want to I want to test
the blocking theory later I guess you
could test that on anyone really because
you're gonna have to clear this place
out so alright we are no longer
suffering or want to suffer oh what a
hacker you still take all - dude you
still take a crapload that was even
percent okay his posture is back to
normal oh boy
yeah Carew's okay so the damage is high
regardless like that's gonna be like
that yeah sure can finish me off
taxi gamer here that's what I'm here for
Griese man says how do people enjoy this
have a game do you like being punished
or some or what uh yeah you got to have
a look as Tamura told me a long time ago
you have to have the right mindset to
play these kind of games and I don't
want to endure so like you either like
these kind of games or you don't right
like I think blood-borne was the closest
to finding a middle ground to some
degree but still very hard game so their
postures way less okay so damaged so it
seems like game oh can you cut the
blocking later when it's safer and safer
okay no damage on block so it looks like
damage on block and then their postures
higher damage looks to be similar I'll
have to test it on the ward yeah
and I got Gustav blood yeah that guy's
posture way back to normal yeah so
posture it seems to be the big
difference and then also the damage will
there be a proper you can't review yeah
there's gonna be possible
so know what I'm saying I don't know if
you've been following the channel or not
either on youtube or on GameSpot calm
but we've kind of changed the review
format sure so now our like we have
something on this site oh no no that
didn't in one shot okay so less damage
for bosses less damage for sure still
still pretty rough yeah but manager
gives you a chance though it gives you a
chance but that uppercut swing was
definitely there
[Music]
oh is that the uppercut cuz that was a
crapload more that's in one shot me w
yeah that's true
grease man says he enjoys difficulty
capable games rather that require a
certain amount of effort and strategy
but honestly I wouldn't call this game
difficult it is cheap and infuriating
it's not cheap I don't think every death
that you experience in any of the souls
boring games is your fault there are
always answers there are always things
you could have done right and it's all
about timing now the one thing in second
row with the deflecting stuff is you can
kind of cheese it a little bit and it's
kind of whatever but yeah if any like
you said to your point it makes it gives
there's more room for forgiveness but if
you die it's your fault I don't think
anything is cheap because like if you
fight a boss enough times you learn the
move sets you learn the mechanics you
should be able to you have all the tools
in front of you to beat them and that's
part of it also the reason why the games
are so loved I guess is because of the
satisfaction that you gain from
overcoming a challenge if you can't
overcome that challenge because you do
have those like you know moments of just
your exhilaration and bliss after you
know like possibly like 30 minutes hour
or hours fighting bosses where you
finally overcome that kind of like
hurdle and there we go okay get that
exciting moment way more manageable
without the girdle mark additional
hardships yeah well yeah yeah so sorry
back to like the new review format it's
more of like a conversation there are
like talking points we do a quick review
for the site now that just has our pros
and cons and a score if that's what
you're looking for but if you're looking
for a more in-depth like review to more
who's saying who did our review for
second row will have a longer kind of
like conversation do you think it's with
is it with Adam or do you know who how
that's going
now we decided it might be David but
he's sick oh then it would be Adam yeah
so anyways yeah so anyways tomorrow
we'll have a longer discussion in terms
of just like his thoughts on the game
he'll they'll also ask a question like
well we'll kind of throw out questions
too or throw out a tweet to the viewers
users all those people to kind of ask
questions that they might want to know
from Tamar's perspective you know about
the game about his experience and things
like that
yeah Morningstar sort that that guy is
tough he took John Luke about eight
hours and he took me like over six so
just keep trying it like that boss is
just super tough yes this is New Game+
John Rogers yeah big grand 2k says it's
always my fault the game holds the
players accountable and it also doesn't
hold your hand it's true I always looked
back cuz I wanted to see him be pissed
in anger but I've gotten hit I've gotten
hit because of it though okay I know fun
fact for everyone out there watching I
didn't know that you could hide in that
little I don't what is that thing
like the little cubbyhole thing that you
know emperors and people get carried
around him and then you get a cool
little cinematic moaner little moment
with the snake that I didn't experience
actually oh I didn't even gone this way
I didn't go around I just waited for him
the peace out and I should have booked
it to the this side I got super lucky
cuz I last time I was with Ben on stream
like he had the red hitmarker on me and
then like he decided to like let me go
Jason Brown asking how long did it take
for you to complete the game for John
Luke he went over most of it with a pre
fine comb toothed fine-tooth comb he
took his time to make sure he saw most
of everything now I forced him to go to
New Game+ today well didn't for us but
he was willing to go to New Game+ today
there was a couple of things he could
have still did actually at the end of
the game so he was over 40 hours and if
he did some of that other stuff I was
just mentioning he probably get another
hour maybe two out of it depending on
how much left I don't know that he had
so over 40 hours for him for me I played
it twice one playthrough was super quick
it was like 20 hours and but I rushed
through a lot of it and I was a pile
Quinn help Ellen Quinn and I got the
short end so that was about 20 hours
the longer ending and my second
playthrough where I knew more about what
was going on that took me about I think
I'm about 33 to 35 hours but I'm still
missing stuff like I didn't even get the
simple text which I'm gonna go get after
their stream because holy [ __ ] how do I
not have that so yeah I think it's like
a 35 to 40 plus our game it your mileage
may vary because it depends on like how
quick you're defeating bosses you know
obviously a lot of people are struggling
on the saint as somebody I mentioned but
you also told me like you're watching Li
Joe who killed him in like 80 attempts
well I think he said I don't know for
him or any attempts total okay well
whatever that is that's better than what
I did you know so but like I said this
game lent it so well he said he's a
Souls born player but it does lend
itself I think to a fighting game kind
of aficionado that guy got top eight at
Evo and so you know like yeah in this
game I feel like even goes carries over
more to like the whole like perrier
style and good junior idol to I killed
that big boy
super far
uh yeah but I would say like as salty as
I am about not getting like the simple
text or whatever is that the that's the
one of the things I love about the game
is how you you miss things your first
playthrough and that just gives you the
motivation to kind of go through it
again also like going through it again
is a lot of fun because I I'll be honest
like when I first played through Sakura
I was not feeling it and everyone in the
office was like oh you know like I'm
having a great time you know like I
don't I like the difficulty and all that
I was just like oh man I'm like I really
just wanted this to be like a more
blood-borne II even though like that's
not fair like this is totally its own
game and its own style and I'm glad that
they're able to kind of like break away
from what you traditionally know and
kind of like do another twist another
span on on kind of the genre but my
second playthrough because I knew more
and I was better at the game and I had I
had more information and I knew were to
get prosthetics and use prosthetics it
was a much more pleasant time so it's
always fun the the second time around
just to kind of go back get what you
missed
get another ending if you didn't get it
like I I'm thinking about now playing it
a third time or new game plussing just
so I can get that other ending that we
knew there was there's there had to be
something right like we found key items
that were like this has to be for
something there's no way it is in its to
like on the nose to not be something and
unfortunately I got too far into the
game where I couldn't trigger it anymore
but like I'm looking forward to you know
doing that that ending as well usually
he's crying right yeah it's different
from the sense that from blood-borne
because you have to block and parry
instead of dodge you gotta learn it all
over again well you also have the
jumping mechanic and McKee recount
there's so many it's there's like so
many yeah there's like a couple more
elements to the fight that you actually
have to worry about and think about that
you didn't have to previous owed you
have the loaded spear one thing I did
were found where do you find it it is I
have it in my videos I can't remember
it's either in the cast I think it's in
the castle somewhere I wanted to see the
effect because apparently the loaded
spear is supposed to be like the anti yo
booze the fire wow this is so weird I've
never heard him say that in English he
said his name he announced it so also
fun fact
have you gotten like the two different
death animations on him or is it always
the same yeah that where the horse
stares hit here okay okay so this one
maybe I just didn't notice the first
timer on also fun fact is you can you
can lasso onto him
as you guys saw there folks and that
helps you kind of like pull yourself
towards him you can technically kind of
pull the chain - ogre - which kind of
helps stagger them a little bit want a
pocket charge oh that didn't work that
time good Perry's oh he's almost ready
for a little a little posh or a little
death blow could you imagine if you
still had the kill you buff on that fun
time huh
there I've only seen one NPC help did
you ever have an NBC healthy more than
once
no just don't only happen in Hirata
right no co-op Jason unfortunately this
morning which actually I don't think
it's unfortunate I always judged people
for the year I don't want I mean it I
get it like I'm a happy that it's there
to help me move all right
happened to help players are struggling
with a boss but there's something about
how it just breaks the AI when you have
two people that it takes away from the
true dreams in my opinion and that's
very kind of a leader some you to say
but whatever Who I am I live that life
but you don't I mean like there's
something about when you do beat the
boss because like it's you and the boss
right which is what makes the game so
great but then when you have two people
it kind of like tethers to one person
that's actually my concern with even
though I don't want to call it animate
Dark Souls it slowly animate the code
bang like I think your partner's
supposed to be with you like that entire
time and so like I've seen boss fights
and I'm like oh it's just following your
buddy you like that takes away from my
attention that I'm having with the boss
and I don't know how I feel about that
so do the sounds over here but barely
here yeah the regards he's an appellate
no problem look at the horse just like
master are you okay
why playing in English I wanted to give
it a shot I played the whole game in
Japanese to plan so you do get memories
again
I wonder if yes because like I said the
Dragon Mask
once you complete it if you guys are
trying to get to Dragon Mask you can
like use skill levels to bump your
attack and I don't know how much it lets
you do it if it's like a one time thing
but that's cool so memories only come
from the shinobi executions which are
like the harder enemies yeah you totally
get to do it ok cool that makes up for
some of them so yeah you do get to
prayer beads maybe don't increase but
attack power continues cool wonder if it
pops twice in my items now oh your
memories I'll be careful about those
maybe it doesn't matter now
Oh two - oh that can be a number held
you can have 99 oh you know that's gonna
be a point of pride like look how many
I've beaten this game no thanks I have
seven beads or whatever I think it's a
good point to stop yeah I think so too I
was gonna actually say like you are you
good with stopping yeah yeah alright
cool so fun facts my new game+ glad we
actually tried it - it's cool to see
that you can engage a like I don't know
would you call like a even harder mode
because it's harder than the demon Bell
for sure it's definitely harder than the
demon Bell yeah just like a New Game+
like challenge mode like New Game+
already definitely makes it tougher yeah
damage is higher that seems very like
fights are gonna be longer because less
their posture takes long yeah and then
you have to be perfect with those
Perry's if you don't want to yeah block
damage yep and then it's and then also
on top of the New Game+ damage there's
they have even more damage so like that
ability that though the warlord was
using on you the uppercut slashed like
one shot at you right but
once you turn that off it was like 70
like at the worst he was like 75% so at
least you have chances to recover
whereas with that debuff it looks very
like you're suffering right so make
sense so you can try that if you want
well we're not sure if you can re-engage
it until New Game+ again or maybe you
get to a point where you get another
shot at it because it said you cannot
back on this for this playthrough this
way
Oh gotcha okay so when he says like you
could do this again later is probably
your next playthrough he's probably
metal your next place okay all right so
at least though if you did trigger it
with Kuro the first time you do have one
more out you have after yeah it's like
they're like hey do you want to
experience this oh you experience this
you want to turn it off it'll give you
an out at any point yeah and it does
stack with the demon buff or the demon
Bell which didn't seem to add too much
more from yeah cool all right so thank
you guys for tuning in we will be back
tomorrow I think the plan and
tentatively is the degeneration zero
that game came out today was from an
avalanche I don't know too much about it
other than what Mike told me which is
like an 80s kind of like survival game
that you could co-op one of four people
cool interesting things got me ex so
yeah come back thank you for tuning in
against wild live we're live 11:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time Monday to Friday
and yeah community Fridays this Friday
MK 11 beta okay Levin beta all right
cool anything else don't lose anything
go plays a key role yeah later
see ya